hello welcome to 3abn today Bible q a my
name is Angela Loma King I'm glad that
you've tuned in
and this is a program where you get your
Bible questions answered from a
wonderful panel that we have here today
thank you for your support of 3abn and
all that you do for your prayers
everything that you do to make this
ministry a worldwide Ministry and we're
thankful for you well let me introduce
our panel today right here Pastor John
Dinsey welcome it's a blessing to be
here and we want to thank everyone for
sending their questions very good
questions some are kind of funny though
but some are very very good
thought-provoking questions how has
Bible q a challenged you well it really
helps you to dig a little further dig a
little more in the Holy scriptures and
as you dig the Lord blesses you and you
learn something new so every every time
we participate in this I think we learn
something new yes I amen I love this
program Daniel Perrin welcome thank you
glad to be here glad to see what answers
God has provided for the questions that
are on our minds and just trying to fit
an answer into three minutes that's not
easy is it God God helps us amen amen
and right across from me is the love of
my life Pastor John Loma King thank you
welcome love you too babe
I love studying the Bible you know that
it's just my book that's where I live
and that's where God's answers are found
and we always pray though for guidance
from above so that we don't do this
program on our own human wisdom well
would you open with prayer please
wonderful loving father gracious God
this is your word your Holy Spirit
inspired meant to write it and we pray
now that as we as we step into its pages
that the holy spirit will be our guide
that our minds will be enlightened our
hearts will be encouraged and those
watching and listening will be not only
informed
but we pray they'll be transformed be
with this program Lord in all aspects of
it may the answers be clear but may
Jesus Christ be exalted in your precious
name we pray
amen amen amen amen now let me explain
this format all question we have
questions that come in from you from all
over the world and they are answered in
three minutes and we have one four
minute answer so question which will
take four minutes to answer and if you
have questions you can eat text them to
618-228-3975 or you can email us at
bibleqa at 3abn dot TV or Instagram dual
we have a lot of Instagram viewers out
there at 3abn underscore official okay
thank you for tuning in and let's start
with our first question all right Pastor
Dinty here we go
what is the Greek word for bread used
that night when Jesus Took bread in
Corinthians
and also the Greek word use for bread
the night before he died
it was not yet the Feast of unleavened
unleavened bread so I'm thinking it was
leaven bread could you explain or
clarify for me what kind of bread does
it say in Greek Carlene and this is an
email
well thank you very much for your
question Carlene and when we look at
First Corinthians chapter 11 and Matthew
26 they are really both talking about
the same night the same experience uh
what people call the Last Supper of
Jesus Christ and so when you look at the
word bread
the Bible itself when you're looking at
the word bread you have to look at the
context to find out what they're talking
about so the word bread in Greek is a
word that is which really means bread a
loaf or thin cake of bread and you have
several references for that in the New
Testament let's go to First Corinthians
chapter 11 and Matthew 26 to see the
verses that you were mentioning First
Corinthians chapter 11 verse 23 for I
have received of the Lord that which I
also
which I also I delivered unto you that
the Lord Jesus the same night in which
he was betrayed took bread and when he
had given thanks he break it and said
take eat this is my body which is broken
for you this do in remembrance of me
so here we have a scripture that tells
us that Jesus is referring to that same
night in Matthew 26 and verse 26 it says
and as they were eating Jesus Took bread
and blessed it and break it and gave it
to the disciples and said take eat this
is my body now you made a reference to
the Feast of unleavened bread and I am
going to go ahead and read Matthew 26 17
which is talking about the same night
the same experience it says now the
first day of the Feast of unleavened
bread that the disciples came to Jesus
saying unto him where will thou that we
prepare for thee to eat the Passover so
yes in the context of Matthew 26 it says
that it was the first day of the Feast
of unleavened bread
so when we're considering that this
bread represents the body of Jesus we
have to understand that Jesus is is to
be uh was supposed to be a lamb without
a spot or blemish without sin he lived a
perfect life tempted in all points like
as we are it says in Hebrews chapter 4
yet without sin so this is why uh the
bread has to be unleavened bread that
represents his body because unleavened
bread represents the purity of the bread
when you're talking about leavened bread
and you have several scriptures that you
look and look look at for that 11
represents sin so this is why for
example you can go in First Corinthians
chapter five
and you can see that 11 represents sin
this is one of the places that you can
go to and there are a couple of other
verses that you can refer to that so 11
represents sin therefore the body of
Jesus representing unleavened bread is
the right symbol that's why we don't use
yeast
you don't use anything to make the bread
rise right represents sin and don't you
love communion Services it is oh yes
beautiful when we have communion and the
end of the year we have our Agape feasts
which is just a super special communion
which is it's just the icing on the cake
so to speak thank you for that okay
Daniel this is an interesting question
what will happen to the Holy Ghost who
flows freely here on Earth when the
saints are taken to heaven
will he argue will he accompany them or
will he remain here on Earth this is
Lynn from Kenya
thank you Lynn for that question in John
16 verse 7 speaking of the Holy Ghost or
Holy Spirit Jesus promised that it is to
your advantage that I go away for if I
do not go away the helper will not come
to you but if I depart I will send him
to you so that's the Holy Spirit and
through the Holy Spirit Jesus promised
to be always with us is fulfilled but
for how long
John 14 verse 16 and 17 says and I will
pray the father and he will give you
another helper that he may abide with
you forever the spirit of Truth whom the
world cannot receive because it neither
sees him nor knows him but you know him
for he dwells with you and will be in
you the work of the holy spirit is a
work that is within us First Corinthians
3 16 says do you not know that you are
the temple of God and that the spirit of
God dwells in you and so this is how
when facing opposition Jesus promises Us
in Luke 12 12 the holy spirit will teach
you in that very hour what you ought to
say because the holy spirit is right
there with us or dwelling within us
so the holy spirit is not confined to a
specific location as as we are we
describe that with the word omnipresent
think of Psalm 139 verse 7. it says
where can I go from your spirit or where
can I flee from your presence wherever I
were to go God's presence is there the
holy spirit is already there
so if I were to move the Holy Spirit
goes with me not limited to place
because wherever the Believers are the
holy spirit is with them so after Jesus
returns where will the righteous be
other righteous filled with the presence
of the holy spirit will be in heaven on
Earth on the other hand we learn this in
Revelation 20 verses 1 to 3 and 7-9 on
the earth Satan is bound here and he's
alone he's made his disorder his
decision his choice is final and there
is no work for the Holy Spirit to do
here on this Earth
so when we returned when we go to heaven
God's presence remains with us God the
Father God the son God the holy spirit
with us continuing to do the work that
God is already doing in us and that is
guiding us directing us completely
reliant on God through the Holy Spirit
and I want to lead you leave you with
second Corinthians 13 verse 14. the
grace of the Lord Jesus Christ that's
power through Jesus and the love of God
and the communion of the Holy Spirit be
with you all amen those blessings of
God's presence are Eternal blessings
that God grants to us so the Holy Spirit
remains with us amen and he does and he
moves in such a way such a the spirit of
God moves in such a beautiful way and
works in our hearts and he tells you
don't do this don't do that go ahead
it's okay and I really appreciate the
spirit of God thank you Daniel okay
honey John you have a four minute
question okay
and this is an interesting one so here
goes I heard a worship leader say that
Jesus chose to imprison himself in a
human body forever
so he's no longer omnipresent nor will
he ever be again
is this biblical truth this is from
yarail
okay thank you so much for that question
you know I would not have used the word
in prison but um I could understand the
reason why he used that because when you
when Jesus came to this earth when he
condescended when he took off the
let me just properly emphasize this when
he robed his divinity
in humanity
he took on a form that he had never had
prior to that and that in that context
he became our brother just like us and
so we find in John 1 verse 1 to 4.
in the beginning was the word and the
Word was with God and the Word was God
and then going to verse 14 and the word
became flesh and dwelt Among Us so Jesus
wrapped himself in humanity to save
Humanity he became like we are so that
we could become like he is Romans 8
verse 3 and 4. it says God did by
sending his own son in the likeness of
sinful Flesh on the account of sin he
condemned sin in the flesh what's the
purpose that the righteous requirement
of the law might be fulfilled in us who
do not walk according to the flesh but
according to the spirit so this this
partaking of us he as as it were became
our brother one with us so that we could
become one with him that's what John 15
talks about I and you you and me this
Oneness that this quantity of this
Fellowship he took on
and that's why when he left the Earth he
says it is expedient that I go away if I
do not go away the holy spirit will not
come and when he comes he'll abide with
you forever that is the Omni presence
the work of Christ continued through the
Omni presence of the Holy Spirit but you
find also Jesus came to take on this
human flesh for the sake of redeeming us
because of the negativity and the Fallen
nature that is found in the human flesh
Hebrews 2 verse 14 in as much than as
the children have partaken of flesh and
blood he himself likewise shared in the
same that through death he might destroy
him who had the power of death that is
the devil so why did Jesus Take on human
flesh it is in this human flesh that he
as the Bible says was tempted in all
points just as we are yet without sin so
the human flesh is a representation of
the sinful nature of Adam but I want to
make something very clear
the sinful nature of Adam
the nature is what Jesus wrapped himself
in not the sinful behavior of Adam this
is so vitally important he was tempted
but yet without sin he understood he
faced it as we would have to face it and
overcome as we would have to overcome by
the strength of that his father provided
him and the Bible says in second
Corinthians 5 21 for he made him who
knew no sin to be sin for us that we
might become the righteousness of God in
him
so forever now when people think of well
you know what happened to him did he go
back to his omnipresent self that is the
work now that's being done by the Holy
Spirit he took on a form to become
eternally our brother I eternally
identified with us taken on the form of
humanity to redeem Humanity from itself
and you know so when we say well
salvation is free no
salvation caused to Jesus everything and
so when we look at Salvation and we
think of what Jesus did to save us let's
not lightly esteem it because he paid
the ultimate price that omniscience he
still has that omnipotence he still
still has but the omnipresence is now
accompanied and accomplished through the
work of the Holy Spirit but is he
all-knowing does he know what's going to
happen everywhere yes he still has that
spiritually and mentally he knows and
understands as it were the end from the
beginning but the omnipresence now is
accomplished through the work of the
Holy Spirit
cue another wonderful answer okay let's
go to Pastor dinzi
why is God's name not used more often
it's really good to acknowledge Jesus
all the time however there are numerous
scriptures that states the father God's
people would know his name example Psalm
83 18 and Isaiah 52 verse 6. there's no
name just an email well thank you for
sending in your question and that is a
very good question and so I would like
to start by reading those scriptures
that you mentioned Psalm 83 Verse 18
that they may know that you whose name
alone is the Lord are the most high over
all the Earth
Isaiah 52 verse 6. therefore my people
shall know my name therefore they shall
know in that day that I am he who speaks
behold it is I uh yes the Lord is fine
with you knowing his name and I his
people do know his name
we do have a situation in the Bible in
which
we have a commandment in Exodus 20 verse
7 that says this is the third
commandment it says you shall not take
the name of the Lord your God in vain
for the Lord will not hold him Guiltless
who takes his name in vain
and so
It is believed that for this reason the
Bible writers were very careful
with the name of God in the Bible and
the uh the Christians had a difficult
time understanding this it was after a
time they understood and you'll see for
example in the verse I just read to you
and the the first one actually that says
that they may know that you whose name
alone is the Lord and if you have a King
James Bible or New King James Version
and many others do the same when they
use the word Lord is capital L capital O
capital r capital D this is following
the U.S tradition in the sense of trying
to keep from saying God's name in vain
they were afraid to violate the
Commandment so when you see capital L
capital O capital r capital D understand
that the name of God is play based there
in the original manuscripts and it's
that what they call the tetragrammaton
which is just four Hebrew uh letters is
y h w h if you want if you would write
them in English y-h-wh there are four
Bible verses in the King James version
that mentioned the name Jehovah with a J
but in the Jewish alphabet there is no J
sound you say Y sound Jehovah and some
people say Yahweh and so this is one of
the reasons why God's name is not
mentioned much in the Bible because they
have
put the tetagrammaton there and in the
English versions they have pretty much
followed the same thing to use capital L
O R D but I can tell you that if you
look at this carefully in your study you
will find that there are over 5 500
verses that mention God's name and
actually
6521 times where it is written in the
Old Testament God's name which is Yahweh
or Jehovah we don't know the correct
pronunciation that has been lost
wow thank you and even the demons know
him don't they and they tremble and they
tremble didn't one of them say Jesus of
Nazareth you they know him we have to be
you know people use Jesus name in vain
conversations and it's unfortunate that
that happens yes but this is how this
happens
wow it was sad when they do that yeah
thank you so much for that okay Daniel
this is an interesting one especially as
a woman for a woman it says can the
church be the bride the bridesmaid
and the wedding guests all right
language that is used in Parables is
often flexible so that a symbol that we
find in one place the Bible might be
interpreted differently elsewhere Pastor
dinzi is already for example mentioned
11 representing uh sin but when we look
in Matthew Chapter 13 we see Jesus using
the leaven to represent also the kingdom
of God and this is why Paul in Romans 6
19 where he's used two examples of death
and slavery he says I speak in human
terms in other words there's limitations
to our human language but Jesus uses the
wedding symbol a couple of times and let
me go through them Matthew 25 1-13 you
have ten virgins people call them
bridesmaids and in this Parable it's
dealing with an individual response
within the church here on Earth so not
everyone in the church on earth makes up
the bride of Christ each bridemaid
bridesmaid or each virgin makes their
own distinct personal decision so this
illustration represents individuals who
are waiting and preparing being filled
with the Holy Spirit Matthew 22 verses 1
to 14 you have another Parable that
Jesus gives of the guests who are
invited to the wedding Feast for the
King's son and this illustration like
the first represents an individual
response where people are responding
individually to the widespread
invitation of the king God invites we
respond by coming and participating in
the wedding
and finally the numerous Old Testament
and New Testament examples of the church
as a body as the bride of Christ
Revelation 19 7 is one of those let us
be glad and rejoice and give him glory
for the marriage of the Lamb has come
and his wife has made herself ready and
so this this image here is not one of
individuals but of the church as a body
made up of individuals second
Corinthians 11 verse 2 Paul says here he
says for I have betrothed you plural you
to one husband that I may represent you
as a chaste virgin to Christ and then in
Ephesians 5 31 and 32 an excellent verse
and the two shall become one flesh
speaking of marriage and then Paul says
this is a great mystery but I speak
concerning Christ and the church
so we got three uses here of of marriage
and so to put them all together and let
their meanings explain to each other
here's what we find the church made up
of individuals is the bride of Christ
each individual has been given an
invitation to be a guest at the wedding
supper and the saved will have prepared
for the return of the bridegroom yet by
yielding to and receiving the Holy
Spirit
so they're the Bridesmaids
and all of us are married so it I like
the relation how the Lord uses that as
one isn't it lots of ways to to see the
relationship with Jesus yes I love it
thank you for that okay John let's go to
math oh please explain Matthew 16 verse
19. okay this is very very very to the
point I think this can be one of my
shortest answers yeah Matthew 16 19 and
I will give you the Keys of the Kingdom
of Heaven
and whatever you bind on Earth will be
bound in heaven and whatever you loose
on Earth will be loosed in heaven this
is very to the point very simple and I'm
not going to take a lot of time on this
Jesus was establishing what we call the
Earthly ecclesiastical system that will
be the foundation of the church on Earth
and in the book of Ephesians chapter 4
it says he gave some to be apostles
some to be prophets some to be
evangelists some to be pastors and some
to be teachers he also gave the church
the ability to judge in matters of
systems of the church and Paul says if
you know do you not know that you will
judge angels and if you judge angels are
you not qualified to judge in the small
matters of man and Humanity matter of
fact there's a whole book called The
Book of Judges so sometimes people say
well don't judge well that means don't
condemn but the church has the authority
to make decisions and the law is in
essence saying In this passage when the
church decides under my guidance on
Earth I will support it in heaven it's
not giving any one individual The
Authority because many people say well
this is talking about Peter the head of
the church no Christ is the head of the
church Ephesians make that very clear
and Peter when he refers to Upon This
Rock I build my church Christ is saying
to Peter Upon This Rock not upon your
rock and First Corinthians chapter 10
said the Wrath that follows them was
Christ so the church is built on Christ
no other Foundation can anyone lay than
that which is laid which is Christ Jesus
so that is the foundation of the church
but the ecclesiastical Authority
recognizes in our church as the pastor
when we make decisions we consult with
the board the board of Elders I don't
make I'm not a
a dictator I don't say well this is how
it's going to be in no other way
all decisions made must be done in
Council there's safety in a multitude of
counsel but those counselors must be in
harmony with God's word which is the
ultimate Authority yet Old Testament
kings that shows men that were young and
inexperienced and we are told don't
choose people that are novices that are
not experienced unless you put the work
in danger and men that must be above
reproach men whose character is known
well in the in the community so that the
ecclesiastical authority of God and the
character of God is not damaged and when
that is done whatever the church binds
on Earth will be bound in heaven why
because they are operating according to
the word of God nutshell it's the
ecclesiastical authority of the church
on Earth and harmony with the
ecclesiastical unfettered undimmed
authority of God in heaven
to you and I like the way our church is
structured yes you like you said you
can't just dictate right in our church
accountability at every level every
level there's accountability thank you
so much for that well if you have just
tuned in and you have a question you're
saying I have a question I want to send
in how do I do that well here's the
information you can text your questions
in to
618-228-3975 or you can email us which
is also good at bibleqa at
3abn.tv so that's the way you can reach
us all right let's go to oh this is a
good question
Pastor dinzi here we go
this is a four minute question so take
your time
can one third of the Angels who were
cast out of Heaven repent and choose to
give their lives back to God this is a
camp meeting question this is
interesting that is indeed a very good
question can one-third of the Angels
repent
you know there are scriptures that talk
about God's love God's mercy in a
wonderful way and we read in Micah
actually chapter seven that it says he
Delights in Mercy and we have many other
scriptures like second Peter chapter 3
that says that God is not willing that
any should perish but that all should
come to repentance so the question is
what about the angels can they repent
and so considering this we must take
some things into uh account and that is
the Angels had privileges that we have
not had as human beings uh and that is
the Angels were there in the very
presence of God being in the very
presence of God they saw his Holiness
his Purity his love unlike we have never
seen that and so the Angels had this
high privilege high honor of being in
the presence of God they they have seen
him they have heard him they know that
he's Love full love and mercy and now
here's the other part because we
understand that
um
we are to love God with all of our heart
all of our mind all of our strength and
our neighbor as ourselves so they Angels
loved God and they also loved Lucifer
and Lucifer came to present to them his
way his ideas I should be worshiped as
well uh I want to sit above the stars of
God I want to sit on the Mount of the
congregation he wanted to take God out
of the picture and be the most high and
he wanted the Adoration of the Angels
well one third of the Angels
approximately decided to follow his plan
his ideas that were not justified in any
way whatsoever and so uh we have this
situation and there was a period of time
that we can say that they had the
opportunity to repent before uh
committing what you would call open
rebellion in heaven they had an
opportunity and God would have worked
out something that we do not have the
information to be able to provide to you
he would have done something for them if
they had not uh did what they call what
we you can say is open Rebellion so
their hearts have become hardened and to
such a degree that they will not repent
no matter what they see what they hear
and there are some scriptures that talk
about human beings coming into that same
type of condition in Matthew Chapter 13
uh beginning in verse 13 I read to you
therefore I speak to them in Parables
because seeing they do not see and
hearing they do not hear nor do they
understand and in them the prophecy of
Isaiah is fulfilled which says hearing
you will hear and shall not understand
and seeing you will see and not perceive
for the hearts of this people have grown
dull and the ears are hard of hearing
and their eyes they have closed lest
they should see with their eyes and hear
with their ears lest they should
understand with their hearts and turns
so that I should heal them God is
willing but they are not so this is a
situation that God is uh he can't do
anything they won't repent no matter
what they have already heard anything
they would never will so unfortunately
this is their condition Unfortunately
they have chosen the evil way and uh it
awaits them the what is described in the
Bible in Revelation chapter 20 and you
when we understand that they will suffer
for what they have done and eventually
die because the Bible says the wages of
sin is death unfortunately a great loss
In Heaven There was God his heart was
broken that they did not accept his love
and mercy and they they chose to rebel
and that's why the Bible says neither
was their place found any more in heaven
they cannot return they have crossed a
well you would say the point of no
return they refused to repent and God is
not able to save anyone that is not
willing to repent
and it's so sad it is indeed you know
they were in the presence of the
Almighty
they they have absolutely no excuse
whatsoever and still God appeals to them
God is a god of love and mercy and you
know what was one-third that fell how
many is left two-thirds right that's
right they're more that be with us than
that be with them that's right so I
praise God thank you
okay Daniel you here's your four minute
question do angels still visit us like
they did in Daniel's time period
I've had wakened dreams and visions of
life-threatening events that happened
the next day was God trying to warn me
does God do that this is from Elizabeth
in Washington
all right thank you Elizabeth for this
question and I want to give you a Bible
answer and a Bible warning according to
the Bible yes Angels do visit us think
of the text in Hebrews 1 14 speaking of
angels it says are they not all
ministering Spirits sent forth to
minister for those who will inherit
salvation well Angels do not always
announce their presence you've probably
heard testimonies or experienced
something where in retrospect you look
back and think that couldn't have been
anything but something Supernatural that
intervened there listen to Hebrews 13
verse 2. do not forget to entertain
strangers for by so doing some have
unwittingly entertained angels this
indicates that we will not recognize
Angels by their experience or by
miraculous signs people didn't even know
they were interacting with angels in
fact we will mostly be unaware of their
presence and there's a reason for that
God wants to keep us focused on on his
word that establishes truth and not
necessarily On Believing some angelic
appearance that we see now many Bible
examples show us that God does and can
give dreams but that does not
necessarily mean that every dream we
receive or every thought that we think
comes from God listen to this warning in
Jeremiah 29 verse 8 thus says the Lord
of hosts the god of Israel do not let
your prophets and your diviners who are
in your midst deceive you nor listen to
your dreams which you caused to be
dreamed so not every dream that we have
necessarily comes from God God is not
given Angels access to our minds they
cannot give us dreams First Kings 8 39
speaking of God says for you alone God
know the hearts of men Angels work by
influence they they communicate they
they do things in the world around us so
that they influence us now we can of
course give access to our minds for
greater influence to evil angels and we
see that the Bible talks about that with
Spirit demon possession now here's the
warning there's more than one kind of
angel that can influence our minds
Saints Satan's angels can influence us
and they influence us to think about
something or imagine An Occurrence and
then they carry out the thing that we've
talked about or the thing that they've
influenced us to think so just because
something appears miraculous or Angelic
or appears to be predictive does not
mean it is a message from God and this
is a warning it's important First
Timothy 4 verse 1 Paul talking here
listen to this the spirit expressly says
that in latter times sun will depart
from the faith giving heed to deceiving
spirits and doctrines of demons in other
words Satan's angels will influence us
to think things that are against the
truth Paul also in second Corinthians 11
14 says and no wonder for Satan himself
transforms himself into an angel of
Light Miracles Angelic appearances and
dreams do not necessarily prove prove
that something is true so how can we
know that a dream comes from God
couple of things that we need to do
every day and number one is ask for the
Holy Spirit John 16 verse 13 says when
he the spirit of Truth has come he will
guide you into all truth and at the end
of that verse and he will tell you
things to come so we need to be asking
for the holy spirit so we are filled
with God's Divine thoughts so we can
recognize anything that comes that is
you know you know put in front of us
that does not go along with God's Will
and then second we've got to search the
Bible daily we are not called to be
interpreters of dreams we are called to
be interpreters of the word of God
through the Holy Spirit Isaiah 8 verse
20 to the law and to the testimony those
are God's words here if they don't speak
according to this word there is no light
in them so we are followers of Jesus
revealed in his word not necessarily
followers of Dreams or Angels that's
right oh well said you know if there's
Spirit of Truth
is in their Spirit of Lies there can be
it can be right Stephen Holy Spirit
unclean spirits exactly yeah yeah and
angels I think I saw my angel I can't
talk about that now
yeah thank you for that that's right
honey you've never called me an angel
before
excuse me my honey okay thank you so
much okay my honey John how do you
receive the Holy Spirit yes segue right
away from Daniel Perrin thank you so
much
going directly to the book of Acts
chapter 2 verse 38 and now there are a
number of scriptures that I'm going to
qualify them one after the other but
let's start with the very first one the
holy spirit is not just given to anybody
just because you ask a lot of people say
well if you ask you get it but there is
a condition you have to be in in order
for that answer to come Acts 2 and verse
38 Peter preached this on the day of
Pentecost he said repent and let every
one of you be baptized
in the name of Jesus Christ for the
remission of sins and you shall receive
the gift of the Holy Spirit now this is
not the gifts of the Spirit he's in the
gift of the Holy Spirit which is a gift
the Lord is saying I'm imparting my Holy
Spirit to you because why they repented
the Lord does not give his Spirit to
those who do not repent this is vitally
important we have to understand we have
to be in right-standing relationship for
God to imbue us with the power So Divine
and so all evasive in our lives for that
leading to be efficacious and to be
authorized we've got to be in harmony
with God that's the only way we could be
in harmony with the leading of his holy
spirit you see in um
in John chapter 14 the Lord made it very
clear this whole concept of just
believing in God a lot of people say
well if I believe in God well the holy
spirit will come to me no Jesus says you
believe in God believe also in me
there's a connection there and then
there are people that say well I know
how the Holy Spirit works well you may
have been awakened to how the Holy
Spirit works but John 3 and verse 8 says
we don't know eventually we become awake
to wow now I see what was happening the
spirit of God was working on me John 3
verse 8 the wind blows where it wishes
and you hear the sound of it but you
cannot tell where it comes from and
where it goes so is everyone who is born
of the spirit so a lot of people when
they say well on such and such a date I
gave my life to the Lord that may have
been the day to be a baptism but the
Holy Spirit was working long before that
why should we be born of the spirit John
3 verse 5 to 7. most assuredly I say to
you unless one is born of the water and
of the spirit he cannot enter the
kingdom of God so when you're being born
again don't just ask for baptism pray I
always pray in baptisms Lord fill that
person with your Holy Spirit and if you
ask what's going to happen Luke 11 13 if
you then being evil know how to give
good gifts to your children how much
more will your heavenly father give the
Holy Spirit to those who ask what's the
purpose of the Holy Spirit not just to
have power John 5 verse I mean acts 5
verse 32 and we are his Witnesses of
these things and so also is the holy
spirit whom God has given to those who
obey him when you obey then he can trust
you with such divine power and by the
way point before I change it back to you
we don't have the Holy Spirit the Holy
Spirit has us that's right amen I have a
little caveat to that
some people say
you have to speak in tongues ah to get
the Holy Spirit
the evidence of the holy spirit being in
your life is by their fruits you know
them the Bible never says by their gifts
you know them by the fruits you know
them the gifts come later when the Lord
can he works on US in US and finally
through us that's where the gifts come
from that's the third stage in the work
of the spirit okay amen thank you okay
let's go to pass a Dempsey this is a
straight direct question
what are the seven horns in Revelation 5
verse 6. this is from Pam
Thank you Pam we start by reading
Revelation chapter 5 and verse 6 and the
Bible says and I looked and behold in
the midst of the throne and of the four
living creatures and in the midst of the
Elder stood a lamb as though it had been
slain having seven horns and seven eyes
which are the seven spirits of God sent
out into all the Earth so we have here
the question what are these seven horns
uh when you look in the Bible you
especially when you look in the Book of
Daniel and there are other places you
see that a horn represents a power and
sometimes you see that it represents
Authority and even a kingdom I'm going
to read to you from Daniel chapter 8 and
verse 20. it says the ram which thou
sawest having two horns are the kings of
media and Persia two horns medium
pressure two different powers identify
here so the the seven horns of of the
Lamb let's look at the word seven we
know that the word seven means
completion means Perfection uh perfect
so this is an interesting picture of
Jesus the lamb that was slain because it
pictures Jesus as uh perfect number
seven and having horns which means power
we have Jesus here letting us know
letting us know that Jesus is perfect in
all authority and power Almighty in
power that's why I read to you now from
Matthew chapter 28 and verse 18. notice
the Declaration of Jesus to his
disciples and Jesus came and spoke to
them saying all authority has been given
to me in heaven and on Earth so we see
here the wonderful description of Jesus
in Revelation Chapter 5 Verse 6 that he
is Almighty and Power and also
all-knowing because having seven eyes as
well all knowing omniscient this is a
mighty wonderful picture of Jesus and I
encourage you to continue studying the
Bible because there are so many things
you know you just can't just read you
have to dig you ask the Lord to help you
understand and when you ask the Lord to
help you understand the Lord begins to
say I think you're ready for this and he
gives you a little more and you keep
studying and the Lord keeps blessing you
with more and it's good to talk to
people that study the Bible because you
can come to understanding more
understanding but remember that Jesus
promised that he would bless us with the
Holy Spirit and guide us into all truth
so this is a again a marvelous picture
of Jesus Almighty in power and authority
and he says search the scriptures right
yes sir for in them you think you have
an eternal life that's right and they
testify of him that's right thank you
for that beautiful okay Daniel another
quick to the point question
who is the prince in Ezekiel 46 this is
Sandy from Louisiana Sandy thank you for
asking not as quick as you might think
here
um most people probably skip over many
people skip over Ezekiel 40 to 48 but
it's good to see someone really
wrestling with serious questions in the
Old Testament there are different ideas
regarding the prince and one of them is
that it's just a physical civil ruler a
carnal Prince the other one is that it's
a spiritual Prince and it is Jesus I
just want to point out a couple of
details that will allow allow you to ask
the holy spirit to guide you and your
understanding of this text in the Book
of Ezekiel things are not going right
spiritually speaking particularly with
the prince and this is referring to the
king zedekiah chapter 21 verse 25 says
now To You O profane Wicked Prince of
Israel whose days has Day Has Come whose
iniquity shall end well will anybody do
what is right chapter 22 verses 27 to 30
the rulers the prophets the priests all
Wicked following in the prince's
footsteps and so verse 30 I sought for a
man who had stand in the gap for me on
behalf of the land that I should not
destroy it and I found no one God's
purpose for making Israel the head and
not the tale appears to be impossible
and hopeless the temple is set to be
destroyed chapter 12 verse 12 says the
prince who is supposed to represent
God's leader he's also set for
Destruction now against that backdrop
Ezekiel records a final Vision on the
prophetic Scroll after chapter 38 and 39
which he sees the final destruction of
evil and wickedness and sin after the
Millennium but this picture that he sees
as the final conclusion he sees the
temple as it should be exactly following
God's pattern and Ezekiel is told in
chapter 40 verse 4 fix your mind on
everything I show you and declare to the
house of Israel everything you see and
then Jesus himself takes him and begins
to measure the temple this is the
sanctuary and every single part of the
sanctuary message is revealed on display
in detail analyzed reflecting on each
part the message of the sanctuary which
is the righteousness and Glory of Christ
is exalted before the people and in the
midst of this we see a prince a ruler of
God's people doing what God's rulers
should do
in chapter 44 verse 4 says Mark well who
may enter the house and all who can go
into the sanctuary chapter 44 the east
gate to the temple is closed except to
the prince the prince has access to
God's Temple chapter 45 the prince does
not oppress but lets his people rest
chapter 45 verse 6 to 15 the prince has
a position of honor and he fulfills the
sacrifices perfectly it is the prince's
role to do that chapter 46 verse 1 and 2
the prince brings God's people into
worship every Sabbath and every new moon
and in verse 18 of chapter 46 the prince
gives an inheritance and does not take
it away these chapters bring us to the
climax where Yahweh shama God himself is
there and so we see both a physical and
a spiritual reality to this Temple
Earthly princes are supposed to
represent at least among God's people
represents the work of what Jesus does
but Jesus alone fulfills the true role
of the prince for his people hey thank
you everything points to Jesus in the
sanctuary service everything this is
just beautiful oh
I'm looking forward to meet now savior
one day on you amen
okay
Pastor Loma King
I would like to know what God's will is
for my life I would um say it again I
would like to know what God's will for
my life is please give me understanding
this is Mina from Minnesota okay or
Mississippi okay yes Ms I'm not sure
exactly what a Mississippi Mississippi
great thank you thank you Mina for this
question this is a question that's
always thought provoking because I've
had people throughout my Ministry and
throughout the years have said I want to
know what God's will is for my life well
let me not burst your bubble but let me
just begin with the question how can we
carry out a will that comes from a god
whose understanding is far above ours
you know the Lord is so clear about his
will and how it accomplishes let's just
go ahead and bring this to the Forefront
Jeremiah 29 11. he begins by saying I
know the plans I have for you declares
the Lord plans to prosper you and not to
harm you to give you a future and to
hope my own experience had I known 40
something years ago that I would be a
pastor I'd say no possible way it's not
going to happen not on this planet this
jockey gamble the pool hustle apartia
not me
but that was God's will what happened
this is how God's will happens Romans 12
verse 2. this has to be a change for
God's will to be revealed do not be
conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
that you may prove what is that good and
acceptable and get it perfect will of
God now get this we are not to know
God's will we are to prove God's will
what is the difference the word there in
the Greek prove means to demonstrate in
other words if you were put on trial as
a Christian would your life be a kind of
life as it was for Peter and John that
they said we these men are ignorant on
an ignorant and unlearned
but it's clear they've been with Jesus
amen the will of God will be revealed
through you when you are transformed we
don't find out God's will and do it
God we find out God and he accomplishes
his will in us we don't find out the
Wilderness and do it on our own we find
out who God is then he accomplishes his
will through US Philippians 2 13 for it
is God who works in you both to Will and
to do of his good pleasure let me make
this point and very clearly you would be
overwhelmed and probably not be able to
handle if God showed you what your life
will be five years from now or 10 years
Daniel even coming to 3ab and I've heard
that story I want to have you preset at
my church when you see what God's plans
are for your life and his will sometimes
it will frighten us to the point so
that's why he keeps it veiled he says
simply make yourself available to me and
I will work in you both to Will and to
do of my good pleasure that's why Paul
speaking about accomplishing God's will
when we come to him Galatians 2 20
it is no longer I who live for Christ
who lives in me and the life I now live
in the flesh this human body I live by
the faith of the Son of God who loved me
and gave himself for me so don't get
bogged down by saying what's God's will
do the first thing get to know who God
is John 17 3 and this is eternal life
that we may know you Jesus the only true
God and Jesus Christ whom you have sent
when we get to know God and his son then
we are taking the first step for God to
work out his will through us not us work
out our will through him is it that
simple get to know God he'll work it out
in you right once you get to know him
right right and submit and commit
yourself to him and he will work and
change you
wow what a wonderful panel we have I'm
excited what we're going to do is take a
break and I know you are going to be
blessed by these questions I know you
are blessed by these questions I am I
feel refreshed renewed revived just
being here on the set and I what we're
going to do we're going to take a break
and when we come back we're going to
talk to these three gentlemen and
they're going to give us a quick recap
of what they what we spoke about today
so you stay tuned we'll be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abian Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back we have a few closing
thoughts pastor denzy concerning Levin
you know the Jews understood this to be
saying I like to read through you from
FC Gilbert practical lessons from the
experience of Israel it says that they
had to do a search for 11 in the house
because they represent sin just previous
to this search the following prayer is
offered blessed art thou O Lord our god
king of the universe who has Sanctified
us with this his Commandments and have
commanded us to remove the leaven then
after that after that they'd search for
the leaven they say this all manner of
Leaven that is in my possession which I
have seen and which I have not seen
which I have removed and which I have
not removed shall be null and accounted
as the dust of the earth they do this
because just in case a mouse came and
grabbed the piece 11 and put it away in
his little cage and they don't see it
they say that and this lemon represents
sin thank you
hey Daniel I just want to encourage
people to ask God to help you both
confirm and apply the truths of his word
just because we said it here doesn't
mean it's true ask God to prove it to
you in his word amen that's right thank
you for that and by the way when we talk
about the gift of the Holy Spirit let's
make it very very clear people think
that the evidence of the holy spirit is
speaking in unusual languages no friends
that's unintelligible the gift of the
spirit was to get the gospel to the
world that did not know it and the world
is filled with diverse languages that's
what happened on the day of Pentecost
check it out in Acts chapter 2 the
spirit of God will open your eyes as he
leads you to understand and appreciate
God's word wow thank you all three of
you the Lord used you in a wonderful way
I was blessed I know our viewers were
blessed and remember this is your
network
thank you for tuning in I'm going to
leave you with a scripture this is from
John 17 17 sanctify them by your truth
your word is truth have a blessed day in
Jesus
[Music]
thank you